el salvador prepara el terreno para el
uso de el bitcoin los detalles los
tienes daniela blandón mi compañera que
está aquí en el estudio con toda la
información de economía de daniela
bienvenida comenzamos en centroamérica
ya va a empezar a usarse el bitcoin el
salvador pérez santiago pues usted
recordará que el salvador se convirtió
en el primer país del mundo en mostrar
interés para oficializar el bitcoin como
moneda en curso legal desde entonces el
debate ha sido amplio porque la
oposición salvadoreña ha criticado al
gobierno de nadie bukele por la falta de
información sobre el uso de la cripta
moneda así como sus posibles riesgos
pese a las críticas del banco del
salvador público las normas para aplicar
la ley de bitcoin en las entidades
financieras
esta ley estará vigente o mejor estará
para comentarios este documento hasta el
6 de septiembre justo un día antes de
que entre en vigencia la normativa el
documento regirá el cumplimiento de
estas normas para los bancos y
sociedades de ahorro y crédito que vayan
a prestar el servicio de convertibilidad
de dólares y bitcoin y también viceversa
a dólares el 9 de junio el congreso
salvadoreño aprobó la ley para el uso
del beat coin sin mayor debate o
discusión parlamentaria en experimentos
en el salvador- hablemos ahora de china
que pretenden regular los salarios altos
pues el presidente chilling prince
solicitó al comité central de finanzas y
economía durante una reunión regular y
ajustar los ingresos excesivamente altos
e irracionales esto con el objetivo
según el gobierno chino de alentar a los
individuos y empresas pues a que
devuelvan más dinero a la sociedad en el
sitio oficial del partido comunista
chino aseguran que la reunión subrayó
los esfuerzos para ajustar los ingresos
excesivos y prohibir los ingresos
ilícitos así como promover la equidad y
la justicia social el documento agrega
que se busca fortalecer el sistema de
asistencia médica y de pensiones
hay que resaltar santiago que china es
cuna de millonarios la lista de forbes
de las personas más ricas del mundo
señala al menos cuatro empresarios de
china en el top 30 entre ellos desde
luego ya cma quien es el fundador de al
igual va muy polémico y esto puede
cambiar hablemos ahora de chile que dio
reportes de crecimiento económico pues
como el resto de países de la región
chile comienza ya a recuperar su
economía tras la pandemia del
coronavirus el banco central de ese país
informó que su economía creció más de lo
previsto en el segundo trimestre del año
con un alza del 1 por ciento frente al
trimestre anterior si la comparación se
hace respecto al mismo período del año
pasado
el pipo mostró un alza del 18,1 por
ciento la mayor de la que se tenga
registro pero hay que tener en cuenta a
santiago como siempre que en este
momento en la economía se desplomó un
poco más del 14% hace un año debido a la
pandemia así que el repunte de ahora es
considerado pues un efecto rebote más
que un regreso a los niveles pre
pandémicos las autoridades le tengo el
ático de cierre mencionaron que la
inversión en este período vamos a un
aumento del 24 por ciento y se mostraron
muy optimistas
daniela vemos ahora de afganistán porque
el fondo monetario internacional le
quitó la ayuda a este país asiático que
pasa por una crisis política
así de santiago la inestabilidad
política social y económica que vive
este país de medio oriente con la
llegada de los talibanes comienza a
inquietar a los organismos económicos
internacionales el fondo monetario
internacional informó que suspendió el
acceso a recursos afganistán incluidos
unos 455 millones de dólares en nuevas
reservas monetarias el organismo
argumenta falta de claridad sobre el
nuevo gobierno talibán esta medida se da
en medio de presiones del gobierno de
eeuu que tiene una participación
mayoritaria en el fondo monetario en
casos como golpes de estado o elecciones
controvertidas pues el fm y depende del
voto de sus miembros para poder entregar
unos fondos a estos gobiernos hablemos
ahora de las bolsas cómo les fue a los
principales parqués en el mundo en la
forma o street cerró en rojo tras
conocerse que la reserva federal podría
retirar estímulos a la economía muy
pronto en europa la bolsa de londres
cayó 0,16 por ciento por cuenta del
retroceso de los títulos mineros
arrastrados por la multinacional bhp que
vendió su segmento de petróleo y en
américa latina la bolsa mexicana avanzó
y alcanzó un máximo histórico cifra el
día las cifras del 7% que cayó la
construcción de viviendas en eeuu en
julio de este año esto después del
frenesí de los primeros meses los
constructores ahora están luchando
contra los altos costos de los insumos y
la escasez de suministros santiago
gracias también las toda la economía en
france24 buenas noches
[Música]
i